Guys I don't know how to say this?
Why am I in a r-room with no furniture or barely anything?
Where is the poster?
Where is the closet?
Where is the beautiful collection of gundam.
I know!!
(internally sad voice)
I know!
Marzia kicked me out!
That's right.
(laughs quietly in background)
(sad music accompanied with REAL crying)
(Slow and sad black and white intro to LWIAY that will probably be replaced)
atataata
I am kidding! (psych!)
I am joking!
(pewds)Marzia we are still fine, right?
(Marzia shouts from far)
YES!
That's not edited in audio. She's actually there, I promise.
And.. We have a new intro!
I've seen this one before it's the top rated one of all time
Come on this has to be the new intro let's look at this
someone put a lot of effort into this
YESSSSSS
(CLAPS)
It's beautiful and unoriginal at the same time, just the way I like it, very nice
Anusdindon you did good, well done
Should we keep that as an intro? Let me know(x2), I like it
I think it's cool we should definitely use-okay great
(Internal screams of pain)
This better make it into LWIAY ohh okay in-title memer
(unintelligible noise)
bUt caN yOu dO tHiS?
Only 399!!!!
Hmmmm what just happened?
I don't know, I really don't knowww (laughing)
WSJ headline: Famous Youtuber "Creator", Pewdiepie, mercilessly attacks endangered frog species
Why would I attack my own species?
It's not like my own pet died
Really, really solid editing here
You can barely tell
that that's photo-imposed
that's almost as good as
the mustache of Superman incredible, well done
OOPSIEEE!
Ten jokes that went too far
Logan Paul's birth
Wait he's 95? Damn, okay well
This explains a lot (laughs)
Up vote if you want pews to do a whole 10 minute video of him
just clapping and saying "meme review"
Yeah I'm sure you guys would love that
It's ehhh I'll do these *oof* post videos every once
in a while and all the comments are just like:
(mimicking) I don't get it
Why is he just clapping? I don't get it
IT'S WHAT YOU WANTED!
stupid idiots!
bunch of morons, you're a bunch of dummy.
dummy - bummy - bum - bum pants.
that's right, on the pewdipie channel.
I call you guys out now (uh oh)
I fight back!
If you're - damn this lens is so cool
I can go so close! hah?
I can fight you back - ow *hurt*
eeeaagh
You're on fire
hahahaha
This is what happens when you don't have internet
realizes he has the shittiest internet in the world
ORLY?
Oh really do I really have the *oof* internet
hey look at that! looks like
someone isn't having *oof* internet any more! (laughs)
(laughs louder)
ahh, just have to move countries guys, that's all.
you have to do to get good internet.
I can't believe people don't realise this.
When you're alive
When you're dead
When pewdiepie starts asking if we have time for bonus meme
It's so sad
we never really have time for bonus meme.
I try my best to make sure.
I'm getting real sick of recording.
bonus memes and it doesn't end up in the.
damn bo- (laughs) -nus meme
I'm not the one that controls!
It's Brad and Sike alright? so really
If you guys want bonus memes so badly
I think you gonna have to mooch upto them and not me
That's right everybody
Way better
(mimicking) Hey Pewdie, you didn't
understand what capitalism and
communism is okay?
*clap clap clap*
Just 'cuz money goes to everyone else
doesn't mean it's communism! (stares)
I'm Swedish okay?
I know all about it
Woah!
Please send it to me
I miss him so much :'(
Look at the logo, that's 10/10 👌
I can't (laughs)
Uh huh, okay
Oh wow! It can spin around, but can it...
(in video)"...do this!"
wow! incredible! (claps)
Science, this is top science stuff
Elon Musk will be impressed I'm sure
Well done, that's honestly pretty cool (laughs)
I like  this new direction
(laughs)
I-I don't know why but
just for now communist memes
are just fine i-it's like
a meme that we can enjoy until the media
ruins yet another meme!
BUT FOR NOW IT'S GREAT 👍
(claps)
Yeah, LWIAY is the only video I have
that actually is fine, every
week it's fine, guess that
means you all post pussy ass memes? ( ͡º ͜ʖ ͡º)
"Does Marzia kow about this?? So sad.."
*Typing noises*
*In depressing voice* This is so sad..
boob..
book..
(Past Pewds) For every boob I see I'll look at two hundred books
*m o r e  typing noises*
(past pewds again) Its really weird, i don't think ive ever read this much in my entire life
It just sort of happened, and ive been loving it
(laughs)
Thats pretty good research. this is almost better than WSJ man. well donE
pewds finally made it to YOUTUBE GAMING
*laughs*
Is that true? I gotta check this.
Nope. Its still Ali-A
WHEREAMI? WHERE? WHERE AM I
YoU FriCkeN FriCkS *autism*
Ok. Alright, Lets see what Ali-A is doing now.
"the real life dance fortnite challenge"
oH how man- H-How good for him, look at all these midrolls.
gOOd for you- good i just- one, two, three, four
Five, Six, Seven. jUst SeveN oF tHem.
Thats great. good for you Ali-A. Good- Good for you
How many midrolls do I get in my videos?
z e r o
As many times as I die in Video games. (keep telling yourself that)
w h y. why
Is it because i say vaganna?
I need answers
* c a n c e r*
LEG day. have you heard about it?
AYYYYHEYHEY AY
SEE THIS IS WHY I DONT HAVE MIDROLLS
God damn it man..
I went to Iceland for you pewds
wOw were at the same part *laughs*
Couldn't he have picked an actual monument that i went to
instead of this random set of houses
*burps* (ew)
Wheres the beard then huh? mMMM
*Its on the screen already*
So hows your day?
What am i kidding I dont care
Just kidding I care too much. I think i should go see a therapist
*back to pewds* *Laughs*
That relief. Thats right.
Don't worry guys I will never play fortnite.
And its not like i played it before it was even out because i got an early copy
But now for some reason I'm just being a complete dick about it *laughs*
Hmmmmmmmm *laughs*
HMMMMMMMM *more laughing*
Granna!
Look at this AntMan2122
Reposting memes from Granna, Pathetic! I mean I'm proud this is how it's done
You don't post memes in the Pewdiepie subreddit, You steal memes
This is all theft *clicky boi*
What the F was that
*TURNS INTO ANGRY PEWDS* CAUSE HE GRABBED ME!
WE WERE GOING FOR A HIGH FIVE! AND HE GRABBED ME!
GUYS STOP PUTTING EXAMPLE OF ME NOT DOING HIGH FIVES!
*normal pewds again* Or handshakes okay I know how to do it I swear to god*you shouldn't do that pewds*
If you ever meet me *self high five* perfect! Here's the thing CONAN!
He went for a handskake doin a high five but you don't grab meet air who grabs meet air?
Ethan! What's wrong with you goddamnit
Why is this my legacy? *laughs*
Oh my god, Damn I got an ad on my videos WOW!
Incredible! and I look so good! I have to blend my ads with my content now It's the only way to do it
Last week my drawing didn't make it into LIWAY I'm trying one more time thanks for the support fellas
I actually reacted to this! so that means Brad or Sike cut it out!
Didn't mean I liked it but they didn't! That's right everybody*laughs*
I made a picture of crying Pewdiepie out of demonetization signs
*Mad Pewds*
Can you stop! why am I wearing these? *laughs*
*laughs*
It wasn't intentional okay alright it's the only branding on it for so long okay please guys please download the like app please so more brands will like me please
I draw and turn people into demons*das scarwey!* so I made one for Felix too it's almost.... like you can't tell the difference
Zero Deaths! That's really cool it reminds of the Death Stranding poster
*High Pitch Voice*"Thank you Namaste that looks very nice"
Well*X3* What is this how did we get mods in this subreddit? I did not mod anyone
Feel free to post whatever you want *yay!* okay there's no rules on the Pewdiepie Subreddit make sure you post your memes in down the below
uuuuh really good memes this week *claps*good job (X2) you got uh plus this week you got a plus everybody what are you gonna do with that?
What are you gonna do with that huh? such clapping much noise
Alright so I'm in Japan I'm gonna stay here for a month umm I'm gonna try to make videos will I'm still here the setup is still in progress
So it's kinda messy but hopefully this will it'll be alright anyway I know it's not the same but uhhmm yeah thumbs up this video
And as always BrooOOFIS- AAAH AH
Does it look like the mic is coming out of me?